Representation is a big issue across
television and film - who gets represented
and what that representation looks like
are two topics that are guaranteed to
start a Twitter fire.
But what does representation of communities and
characters that usually don't get the
spotlight look like beyond simply being
present in a story.
Ramy is a new show on Hulu that follows a very particular Arab
American Muslim family as the main
character, this guy, tries to navigate his
faith and, well, his libido.
I got to sit down with the creator and star of the
show - Rami Youssef - to talk about what authentic
representation can look like.
I do want to say two quick things one, I actually
don't watch "Game of Thrones"
even though probably everyone else does.
I don't either.
- You don't either?
No.
I just know.
When you think about representation, like what does that word actually mean to you?
I think it's really important to find a character
with a point of view and really live
with them and sit in their problems.
I think showing them at their most
vulnerable, showing them at their weakest,
showing them at their most flawed is the
most fun way to represent somebody
because we all have those
weaknesses, we all have those flaws.
I feel like the Ramy character is designed for us to see our vulnerable selves. I don't really
believe in, you know, giving someone from
a certain culture three lines in one
scene and then saying 'You know, we did it. We covered it.' I believe in giving that
person an entire show, giving that person
an entire episode, giving that person, you
know, scope to be in a scene, in their
problems, without dialogue.
So what is something that you really want the
various audiences that are watching this
show? What do you want them to take away?
We did an early testing of this show
that opened up at the mosque. All the
people in testing thought the show is
about terrorism because it was in a
mosque, and people were speaking Arabic.
So this is the mindset that people are
entering. And I hope at the very least,
we've created something that shows
people, people go to the mosque for a
sense of community to solve their
problems, to see their friends, that
people pray and say, "Allah Akbar," to find
comfort, to find direction,
to find guidance and nothing more than that.
Then who does Ramy ultimately represent? How
accurate is it even to your own life?
I mean I think right off the bat a lot of
the facts are different.
He's not a standup comedian - that's probably the
only thing that helps my family stomach
watching the show is that they're like,
OK, at least it's clearly not us.
I tried to imagine a family that was less
communicative than mine. I tried to
imagine a character that didn't have a
creative outlet like I do.
Someone that was a little more stuck and that was a
little more in their problems.
There's been a lot chatter already on
Twitter. How do you respond to people who are reacting?
You don't have to watch it
and I've never said that this would
represent you ... I mean, this
show is called "Ramy" you know, I think it
offers something that hasn't been in pop
culture in this way. I don't think we've
seen a practicing Arab Muslim put that
on display.
- And I do think a lot of this
show is algebraic in a sense. I think,
OK, we have a crazy uncle who says
sexist, homophobic, anti-Semitic things.
And if you are in an Arab family, maybe
you have an uncle like that maybe you
don't. If you are in a Jewish family, you
have that uncle who maybe says all those
things about Muslims and Palestinians.
If you are in a white family, you have that
uncle who says those things about Black people.
I noticed how one of the cool
things about the show is that like it's
very unapologetically Muslim as well,
right?
- Yeah.
It really normalizes Islamic
practice in a way that's
not like a caricature.
Well, I mean everyone wants you
to have a good hummus recipe when they
find out you're Muslim they don't want
to hear you talk about Allah like that
that's a lot... But I think, you know,
figuring out ways to talk about it is a
lot of what's behind the show, too.
You know, how how can we, you know, be as
authentic as possible to, you know,
wherever we're at.
- It seems like all the
female characters in some way or another
kind of defined by their like proximity
to sex. And so I'm curious as to whether
we're gonna see more female character
development as the show goes on.
I want more nuance for the women in the show.
Absolutely. This show is called "Ramy."
To already get two episodes that I'm not
even in, in the first season of a show
that is based on my stand-up
was like a huge
coup with the network. I
think that we talk about sex a lot in
the show. Sex is also a big part of the
Muslim world but we're acting like it's
not part of our daily lives.
How do you respond to the idea that any
representation of a community becomes
representation of all, whether it's from
that community itself, so Muslims may be
watching this show and thinking like, "Oh
my God, is this supposed to represent all
of us?" How do you respond to something like that?
I feel for people who want to
see themselves on screen. We don't have a lot of stories.
At the same time, I think
that to try and do it all is really
damaging. And I think what we do too is
we hurt our creators because when
something comes out and all that happens
is like an onslaught of shooting it down,
there is the Black Muslim creator who's
now a little afraid of taking a risk on
their show.
There is the South Asian creator who's a
little bit afraid. There is the woman
who's a little bit afraid because
there's no way to cut it where people
aren't going to be upset.
- So where does "Ramy" go from here?
- I think he continues to
expand. I think he I think he starts to
realize his hypocrisies in a deeper way.
I think I want to see him realize the
way his actions are affecting other
people in his life a little bit more. And
also as a show, I really want to dive
into more nuances of the people who are
around him.
If there's anything you want
to say to our audience right into the camera.
Oh, no, I I've never wanted to do anything
to camera ever.
Really?
Dead serious. Yeah. It freaks me out.